Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Isabelle Andrieu
A qualcuno di voi è senz'altro capitato
di provare a seguire una dieta.
Se non siete timidi, alzate la mano.
(Risate)
Va bene.
Poi magari una parte di voi
non è arrivata in fondo,
perché ad un certo punto non ce la fa più,
perché il cibo non è poi
tanto buono, diciamolo.
E poi è sempre la stessa minestra.
I meno timidi ancora alzino la mano.
Ecco, la buona notizia
è che non è colpa vostra.
Sono qua per convincervi.
Queste diete sono perfette
dal punto di vista nutrizionale,
sono completamente sbagliate
dal punto di vista gastronomico.
Cosa significa questo?
Significa che l'uomo non è banalmente
un organismo da nutrire.
Noi non abbiamo solo
uno stomaco e un intestino
che digeriscono e assimilano il cibo.
Quando ci portano davanti un piatto
abbiamo due occhi che lo contemplano,
si fanno magari ingolosire
dai colori, dalle forme,
abbiamo un naso che sente i profumi,
abbiamo una bocca che sente i sapori,
percepisce le consistenze
e addirittura due orecchie che sentono
la croccantezza quando mastichiamo.
Tutti e cinque i sensi
sono coinvolti quando mangiamo.
Quando mangiamo, questi sensi
trasmettono sensazioni alla nostra mente,
generano emozioni, suscitano ricordi.
Tutto questo avviene in noi
mentre mangiamo
e non possiamo farne a meno,
perché noi siamo costretti a mangiare.
Ogni giorno,
più volte al giorno,
tutti i giorni della nostra vita,
noi dobbiamo sottoporci
a questa esperienza.
E questa esperienza
può essere positiva o negativa,
può essere fonte di gioia,
può essere noia,
può essere anche disgusto,
ma è un problema che dobbiamo risolvere.
Perché ci può portare
anche a delle profonde depressioni.
Adesso non vi chiedo di alzare la mano,
però a me capita,
se mangio male mi sento di cattivo umore
e non lavoro nemmeno bene.
Se invece ho mangiato bene
dimostro un teorema.
A me è successo. È successo.
Bene, cosa fa l'uomo da che mondo è mondo
per risolvere questo problema?
Si è inventato la cucina, signori.
Perché l'uomo è l'unico
animale che cucina.
Se noi cuciniamo,
è perché siamo costretti ad affrontare
questo problema della sensorialità,
perché possiamo benissimo vivere
senza televisione, senza elettricità,
addirittura senza leggere
o senza parlare, in casi estremi,
ma se non mangiamo, moriamo.
È nata la cucina,
e la cucina è talmente importante
che addirittura, ad oggi,
in tanti ospedali stiamo studiando
la cosiddetta "Terapia del pasto",
perché mangiare bene
dal punto di vista sensoriale,
favorisce le guarigioni, le accelera.
Faccio un esempio: avete presente
quei vassoi tipici tristi dell'ospedale,
i vassoi marroni o bianco pallido sporco
con sopra la mela cotta,
la minestrina gialla
e se vi va bene un formaggino bianco.
Adesso immaginate un bel vassoio colorato,
con sopra dei cibi variopinti, profumati,
con delle forme fantasiose.
Vi viene voglia di mangiarli
e avete più appagamento.
Siete più felici e guarite prima.
Benissimo.
In tutto questo allora io mi aspetto
che la scienza mi dia una forte mano
per risolvere questo problema.
Non è così semplice, in realtà.
La scienza è molto brava
a dirci cosa fa bene al nostro corpo,
se però teniamo la stessa prospettiva,
cioè di una scienza che ci deve dire
cosa è buono da mangiare,
abbiamo già perso in partenza,
perché il concetto di "buono da mangiare"
non è un concetto oggettivo,
non è un concetto scientifico.
Il buono da mangiare
varia da cultura a cultura,
da paese a paese, da persona a persona,
e anche, nella vostra giornata,
dalla mattina alla sera.
Vi piace mangiare cose diverse.
Però dobbiamo cambiare la prospettiva.
Noi non vogliamo l'uomo per la scienza,
vogliamo la scienza per l'uomo,
la scienza che viene incontro all'uomo.
Allora la scienza deve farsi dire
dall'uomo cosa gli piace
e poi aiutarlo a realizzare
questo cibo che gli piace.
Come può farlo?
La parola è una sola: innovazione.
La cucina, da quando esiste,
ha bisogno costante di innovazione.
Se prendete il ricettario più antico
degli antichi romani,
vedete che mangiavano
mammelle di mucca, ghiri,
cervella come dolcificante
e condivano tutto
con una salsa a base di pesce putrefatto.
Nel rinascimento speziavano tutto,
e il pomodoro e la patata
sono arrivati nella nostra alimentazione
solo alla fine del 700.
Quindi la cucina cambia in continuazione.
La cucina deve adeguarsi
al cambiamento del mondo e della società.
Il problema è che questi cambiamenti,
negli ultimi anni
sono diventati talmente rapidi
che la cucina deve evolversi
ancora più rapidamente.
Quindi, innovazione.
Ma perché c'è bisogno di innovazione?
Sono diversi i motivi.
Allora, guardate e fatevi una risata
con questo manifesto anni '50.
Ne esiste anche una versione italiana,
ma questa è stupenda
perché è internazionale.
Il burro è buono per te
e buono per la tua salute.
Consigli nutrizionali:
il burro è scivoloso,
mangiatene più che potete
perché così lubrificate
le vene e le arterie.
Erano gli anni '50, gli anni '50, ok?
Ecco, diciamo che adesso,
se vedete un bambino con davanti
quei panetti di burro che mangia così,
prendete i genitori
e togliete la patria potestà.
(Risate)
Adesso magari vogliamo ridurre
il tono di grassi saturi,
dobbiamo cercare di fare una pasta frolla
non con il burro ma magari con olio;
è molto difficile, poi ve lo dirò.
Quindi cambiano le nostre
conoscenze nutrizionali,
cambiano in continuazione.
La medicina si evolve.
Ma non è solo questo,
cambiano anche gli ingredienti
a disposizione.
Vi ho già citato l'esempio
degli antichi romani.
Vi posso citare i miei nonni
che hanno vissuto serenamente
senza sapere cosa fosse
un kiwi, per esempio.
Mentre voi adesso lo usate
per decorare di verde le vostre torte.
E poi c'è anche altro,
perché cambiano i gusti,
perché noi nutriamo il corpo
ma anche la mente.
Il grande antropologo Lévi-Strauss
diceva che un cibo
prima ancora che buono da mangiare
deve essere buono da pensare.
Cambiano i gusti
e questo lo sappiamo da sempre.
Guardate, questa è una pagina
di un almanacco francese del 1760,
siamo prima della Rivoluzione
e prima che Parmentier
introducesse il consumo della patata.
Siamo a questi livelli.
C'è una filastrocca che rappresenta
il mestiere della cuoca e dice:
"Ogni anno, una nouvelle cuisine",
nuova cucina, lo usavano già allora,
"Perché ogni anno cambiano i gusti
e ogni giorno nuovi ragù.
Siate dunque una chimica, Justine",
che è il nome della cuoca.
1760, era già chiaro tutto.
Era già chiaro che la scienza
doveva contribuire all'innovazione.
Allora, la scienza
che dominava era la chimica.
Ma cosa c'è di così difficile,
mi direte, nell'innovare?
Infondo, prendo tre ingredienti,
li combino insieme e ho già innovato.
No, non è così facile.
Non è neanche una questione di chimica.
La chimica è la scienza
che governa i sapori e i profumi,
e in parte anche i colori.
Aggiustare i sapori e i profumi
non è difficile,
se non è dolce aggiungete zucchero
oppure un dolcificante,
se non è abbastanza acido mettete l'aceto.
Il sale poi non ne parliamo.
Il punto chiave,
la vera difficoltà della creazione
in cucina sono le strutture,
le consistenze.
Provate a fare una frolla
e a metterci dentro l'olio
al posto del burro.
Ma anche soltanto
se ci mettete il fruttosio,
che sembra uno zucchero più salutare,
al posto del solito zucchero da cucina,
la frolla viene molliccia,
non sarà mai secca
e non sarà mai croccante.
Una meringa appiccica
se ci mettete il fruttosio.
Il problema delle strutture
è un problema pazzescamente difficile
e non a caso la grande rivoluzione
nella cucina moderna,
contemporanea anzi,
comincia proprio dall'affrontare
il problema delle nuove strutture.
La rivoluzione comincia
con questo piatto storico:
1994, Ferran Adrià,
destinato a diventare
il più grande cuoco della sua epoca,
si inventa questa minestra
di verdure testurizzata.
Ha "destrutturato"
il minestrone. Qual è l'idea?
Il minestrone è buono,
ci sono delle buone verdure,
ma non è elegante come consistenza,
non lo proporreste mai in un ristorante
a tre stelle, di alta cucina.
Se invece cambio le consistenze,
rendo il tutto più piacevole.
Provate a pensare:
patate farinose, fagioli fibrosi,
il basilico sfatto.
Lui ha messo una gelatina di basilico,
ma soprattutto ha inserito
una grande novità:
quella spuma violetta
che vedete sulla destra
è una spuma di barbabietola
che ha ottenuto con il sifone,
che è lo strumento che sta al centro.
Il sifone lo avevano inventato
gli austriaci per montare la panna
più rapidamente.
Lui realizza il primo hackeraggio
della cucina moderna,
cioè usa il sifone per fare qualcosa
di completamente diverso
rispetto alla sua funzione originaria.
Riesce ad ottenere questa spuma
che sa solo di barbabietola.
Perché prima si facevano le mousse,
ma si aggiungevano le uova e la panna,
quindi le mousse sapevano di barbabietola,
ma anche di uova e di panna.
Lui ottiene un sapore in purezza.
Va avanti esplorando,
ma si rende conto che il cuoco brancola
senza la scienza che lo aiuta.
Quindi nel 1997 pubblica un libro
che è una pietra miliare
nella storia della cucina
e si intitola "I segreti de El Bulli",
dove scrive questa affermazione profetica:
"Se riusciamo ad avviare
una collaborazione
fra cuochi e scienziati,
i confini si aprono
e le possibilità per la nuova
arte culinaria sono illimitate".
È il '97.
Timidamente, nei primi anni 2000
cominciamo le prime collaborazioni.
In realtà, lo sviluppo della scienza
era arrivato proprio al momento giusto,
perché in quegli anni
era nata una nuova disciplina
che gli inglesi chiamano "Soft matter",
i francesi "Matière molle",
tutta Europa la chiama "materia molle",
noi in Italia la chiamiamo
"Materia soffice"
perché ci fa un po' schifo
parlare di materia molle
e il mio corso all'università
si chiama Fisica della materia soffice,
ma di fatto è materia molle.
Giusto due parole per dirvi che cos'è:
a scuola vi insegnano
che la materia ha tre stati,
solido, liquido e gassoso.
Il solido è rigido, indeformabile,
ha una forma e un volume propri.
Il liquido ha un volume assegnato,
ma occupa la forma del recipiente.
Il gas invece si espande liberamente.
Bene, con questa classificazione,
in cucina non ci fate niente.
Trattate il sale
e lo zucchero, poi finisce lì,
perché una marmellata
non è né solida né liquida,
la polenta non ne parliamo,
la panna montata...
Ma, guardate, non è solo
questione di cucina.
La materia della nostra quotidianità
non rientra in queste classificazioni.
Guardiate i vestiti che avete addosso,
sono armature? Sono scafandri?
Sono giacche, devono prendere
la forma del corpo.
Quindi non sono solidi,
non sono neanche liquidi.
Sono materia soffice.
Ecco, questa è la materia soffice.
La materia soffice
diventa lo strumento di battaglia,
lo strumento creativo
di questa nuova cucina
e arriviamo ad Adrià
sulla copertina del New York
Times Magazine del 2003
con una sua creazione
basata su questi studi.
È un'aria, vedete. Un'aria. Cos'è un'aria?
È una schiuma molto rarefatta,
come quella della birra,
come quella del cappuccino,
che ha una funzione gastronomica
molto interessante,
perché ci porta in bocca
degli aromi, anche dei sapori,
senza riempirla di materia,
per cui il gas svapora.
Con un'aria io vi posso far mangiare
il tabacco sopra ad un gelato.
Con un'aria voi a casa
prendete succo di limone,
un po' di lecitina di soia,
montate con il minipimer,
la mettete su un pesce, su una sogliola.
Invece di uccidermi la sogliola
con le gocce di limone
che vi corrodono la bocca,
date un leggero sentore di limone
al vostro pesce
e non date nemmeno calorie.
Meglio di così...
Andiamo avanti.
Adrià è veramente un genio.
Il caviale di melone.
Questo è un primo esempio
delle innovazioni portate
da questa grande rivoluzione.
Usando una sostanza nuova,
già usata dall'industria alimentare,
che si chiama alginato di sodio,
prepara queste palline che sono morbide
e gommose all'esterno
e ripiene di un gustosissimo
succo di limone concentrato all'interno.
Caviale di melone.
Con un altro ingrediente
che si chiama gomma xantanta,
Andoni Luis Aduriz,
quest'altro grande cuoco spagnolo,
realizza questo dolce
che si chiama Vanità.
La Vanità sono queste bolle di cioccolato
che svaniscono quando le mangiate.
Ma il tema delle spugne
è costante nella cucina di Aduriz.
Guardate questa bellissima spugna
che ha creato imitando una forma naturale.
Ci sono nuovi ingredienti.
Adesso, al supermercato
comprate l'agar agar,
vent'anni fa non sapevate
nemmeno cosa fosse.
Poi ci sono nuovi strumenti:
questo è l'azoto liquido.
Facciamo un gelato in dieci secondi
stappando una bottiglia di Moscato
e mantecandola all'istante.
Vi preannuncio che nella pausa pranzo
potrete assaggiare una creazione
preparata con l'azoto liquido
che sono i pop-corn di panna montata
al caffè e alla vaniglia.
Proseguiamo.
Piatto iconico della cucina contemporanea:
sulla destra "Marimontagna",
mari e monti di Joan Roca,
un'ostrica cruda servita
su un distillato di terra di bosco.
Come fa a distillare la terra di bosco?
Con questo strano marchingegno
che vedete alla sinistra.
Si chiama rotovapor,
è un distillatore a bassa pressione
che fa bollire l'acqua a 40 gradi.
A quel punto distillate senza cuocere,
quindi mantenete gli aromi crudi
di tutto quello che avete,
perfino del muschio.
Su questa tecnologia si basa anche questa,
una pentola a depressione.
Togliamo l'aria. Perché togliamo l'aria?
Perché così l'acqua bolle
a temperature basse
e ci facciamo le fritture
a bassa temperatura,
che sono croccantissime
ma non bruciano mai.
Non si scuriscono e non sono nemmeno
dannose come le fritture normali.
Non soltanto i nuovi strumenti
hanno caratterizzato la nuova cucina.
Guardate, questa è una creazione
del nostro Carlo Cracco.
Sono gli spaghetti di solo tuorlo
che ha ottenuto con la sua tecnica
dell'uovo marinato,
che è tipica della cucina
molecolare italiana.
È una cucina che sfrutta
ingredienti tradizionali,
utensili assolutamente tradizionali,
ma usati in modo nuovo e creativo.
Carlo ha preso un tuorlo d'uovo,
l'ha messo su un letto di zucchero e sale,
l'ha ricoperto di zucchero e sale,
dopo qualche ora il tuorlo si rapprende,
si asciuga, diventa lavorabile
e ci fate gli spaghetti di solo tuorlo.
Con tecniche simili
anni fa ci siamo inventati
la frittura nel glucosio:
friggiamo nello zucchero fuso
così non ungiamo e abbiamo
tutta una serie di altri vantaggi.
Un altro piatto che vi lascio
come esercizio quando tornate a casa
si chiama la cagliata d'uovo.
Prendete una padella,
ci rompete dentro due, tre,
quattro uova, quelle che volete.
Poi, invece di cuocerle,
versate dentro alcol etilico per liquori.
Mescolate, si rapprende all'istante
come quando si fa il formaggio.
Sembra quasi cotto,
l'albume diventa bianco.
A questo punto lo strizzate,
altrimenti vi ubriacate,
togliete l'alcol in eccesso.
Lo potete anche lavare
con un po' d'acqua fredda -
anzi, meglio lavarlo.
Strizzate tutto e avete una ricottina,
la cagliata d'uovo.
Potete mangiarla in mille modi,
l'ultimo esperimento che ho fatto
è condita con un po' di miele
e vi garantisco che è fantastica,
ma sbizzarritevi.
È una materia prima neutra,
potete fare quello che volete.
Bene, tutte le cose che vi ho raccontato,
adesso finalmente hanno preso forma.
Come vedete, la gastronomia è una scienza.
Allora noi tutti che abbiamo lavorato
su tutto questo negli ultimi anni,
ad un certo punto ci siamo detti,
"È bene che questi lavori
non vadano persi.
È bene dire che bisognerebbe creare
una nuova disciplina,
che si chiama Gastronomia scientifica".
Ci siamo riuniti a marzo a Barcellona,
all'università, in una veste
estremamente ufficiale
e ne è uscito questo
"Manifesto di Barcellona"
che ora sta girando per il mondo,
dove si sostiene esattamente
quello che vi ho raccontato
in questo quarto d'ora,
cioè che l'uomo ha bisogno di mangiar bene
per il suo benessere psicofisico.
Che la cucina è un'attività
caratterizzante
dell'umanità in quanto tale,
culturalmente.
Che la gastronomia
deve essere una disciplina olistica,
non si può ridurre tutto a fisica,
chimica o biologia.
Ci sono aspetti psicologici,
emozionali, filosofici, culturali.
Questo è il Manifesto di Barcellona.
Ma la cosa più bella
è che Manifesto di Barcellona
realizza alla perfezione
una sorta di sogno, di profezia,
che ci ha lasciato scritto
il primo gastronomo dell'età moderna,
un signore che si chiamava
Brillat-Savarin,
primi dell'800,
che scrive un trattato intitolato
"La fisiologia del gusto".
All'inizio di questo trattato
pone una serie di aforismi
e ce n'è uno in particolare
che era veramente profetico, ed è questo.
Dice: "La scoperta di un piatto nuovo
giova più alla felicità dell'uomo
che non la scoperta di una nuova stella".
Grazie.
(Applausi)